dominated by me and then also I've done
some of the most extreme sex acts on
camera that guys can't swallow or get
past I currently do kind of look like a
little bit of a lonely eye there's
another aspect where guys only want to
date me to like show show me off to
other people or their friends they
immediately treat me like the Adriana
Adriana chechik like experience right so
like if I was gonna go meet a guy like
they would never hold my hand or
anything the first thing they do is they
try and like have sex with me so it's
really like disheartening to be honest
and I've kind of just given up I feel
like sadly I actually feel like I might
not ever find like a boyfriend like that
so there you have it folks from the
horse's mouth
doing corn
will make it tougher to date